well what I would say is that there is
no such thing as too ordinary to write
about whether that's life or a scene in
a novel now what's interesting to people
whether it's memoir or fiction is the
truth true now what does that mean what
does that mean well sometimes often the
truth is difficult to arrive at and the
reason is not because we know the truth
but but are going to sidestep around it
but because we are we we individually do
you have not faced it I'm not faced it
or have not looked close enough now
there's a there's a scene in a book it's
a novel and I can't remember the author
I think it might have been uptight but
I'm not sure I believe it took place in
like the 1930s in a farmhouse in the
Midwest and it was a very hot night and
somebody was upstairs in one of the
bedrooms getting ready to go to sleep
and they were naked underneath a sheet
the window is open because it was so hot
and out the window they heard gun shot a
rifle what they did is they move the
sheet off their body and listened and
when I read that it stopped me and I
thought yes that's right that's right
now it's a little bit odd if you think
about it if if you've heard a gunshot in
this sweltering summer evening in the
30s or 40s and why would you why would
you move the sheet off your body but and
it doesn't make any sense when you think
about it like that but if you put
yourself into that bed in that farmhouse
and you hear that gunshot
you will very quickly discover that even
the slightest movement of that sheet
over your skin will generate noise in
your head like a sound so you have to
immediately get rid of it so you can
listen now a less careful writer would
have said something like um I don't know
what's a good 1930s name what is good
1930s named Gordon angled his ear to the
window and you know uh in in listen for
it whatever sound and you would read
that and then you would move on and you
wouldn't think about it and and you
wouldn't know jet to it and you wouldn't
you wouldn't probably have any opinion
at all and you certainly understand what
had happened but when you read the scene
with the sheet that puts you there
you've experienced it and that some at
it's hard it's a pretty ordinary moment
you know the the thing for someone just
starting off is to write a lot of people
in writing writing programs spend a lot
of time writing assignments and very
little time on their own writing you
need to there's a certain athletic
quality the unique take into
consideration you need to have a limber
limber fingers you know whether you
write with your fingers or type on your
laptop but you need to have a limber
mind and you need to be able to the goal
is to write without judging what you've
written at least right away and without
editing right away because if you have
an opinion too quickly it could be wrong
so the most important thing for a writer
to do is to write
it really doesn't matter what you write
as long as you are able to to write
fluidly very very quickly very quickly
they're effortlessly it needs to become
not second nature but really first
nature to you and and read you need to
read and you need to read you know
excellent books and then some bad books
not as many bad books but some bad books
so that you can see what both look like
and why both are what they are you know
one thing is was so helpful to me was to
read books that I I didn't begin reading
till I was 24 and when I did begin
reading I could read I just I didn't but
when I did begin i chose books because
of the cover I did I didn't have any
sort of formal education so the names of
authors didn't mean anything at all to
me but the covers did and that proved to
be a very interesting way to choose
books and it did expose me to some that
I wouldn't choose on my own that are
among my favorite books so you know a
lot of guys starting off writing you
know like Seattle kind of skateboarder
guys want to write they might not pick
up the House of Mirth you know but they
should they should pick up the house of
mirth that's a very very good book or I
don't know you know Moby Dick moby dick
you know I don't want to read about a
big fish you know about a whale I want
to about but i remember when i read the
first page of Moby Dick I thought is
this is wait a minute is is this what I
think you know and it's you can you can
sort of tell that it must have been kind
of subversive in its day you know kind
of dave eggers of its day just like oh
well what is IRA
his name Rosemary's Baby the novel
Rosemary's Baby if you just read the
first three pages you might even be too
but now three pages you'll see that it's
a period of its period it's just piss
elegant it is a piss elegant book that
is brilliantly constructed to create
just very very uncomfortable tension I
think it's on the third page when the
time is announced and the clock is set
and while these aren't things you
necessarily will take notes on and
become consciously aware of if you read
them and you're fully in the book you
have now experienced them and that will
help your writing so I think I would try
to encourage people to write less with
their brain you know less less with and
more from a more subconscious from a
subconscious area to trust you've really
got to make a leap of faith and trust
trust that that you will know what to do
you know when it when the time comes